[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
auch heute wieder Demos in zahlreichen
deutschen Städten von Bremen bis
Magdeburg die größte dieses Wochenendes
war gestern in Berlin mit mehr als 150
000 Teilnehmern wenn parallel dazu in
einer Kleinstadt ein paar hundert oder
tausend Menschen auf die Straße gehen
liefert das natürlich nicht ganz so
beeindruckende Fernsehbilder ist aber
eigentlich gesellschaftspolitisch noch
relevanter und erfordert gegebenenfalls
auch Mut dort auf die Straße zu gehen wo
man weiß dass das den Nachbarn aufstößt
und möglicherweise Neonazis auflaufen
werden um zu stören und einzuschüchtern
Steffi Moritz berichtet
ein bisschen Bammel hat Konstanze
bornkampf schon das Regen und Wind die
Freiberger heute davon abhalten könnten
dem Aufruf ihres Netzwerkes Freiberg für
alle zu folgen denn die Demokratie sei
in
Gefahr es geht eben wirklich darum diese
demokratiefahne hochzuhalten und die
Demokratie zu verteidigen das ist
einfach wichtig doch schnell fülllt sich
der Marktplatz gut 600 Leute sind
gekommen etwa halb so viel wie letztes
Mal Demo gegen Rechtsextremismus in
Freiberg einer Kleinstadt im Erzgebirge
42 000 Einwohner rund 30%
afdwähler man kennt sich man braucht
hier Mut um Gesicht zu zeigen ich glaube
es geht immer ein bisschen Mut dazu das
zu zeigen ja aber also für mich ist es
eine Selbstverständlichkeit ich habe
mich schon manchmal schwer getan da zu
sagen ich gehe jetzt auch mal auf so
eine Demonstration oder Kundgebung also
es ist eine Kleinstadt glaube ich schon
schon schwieriger ich meine wir sehen es
ja auch hier in der Gegend werden werden
Einzelhändler eingeschichtert wenn sie
gegen Nazis auf ihre Prospekte schreiben
und ich denke schon dass mehr Mut
erfordert als als irgendwie in Berlin
Konstanze bohnkampf ist mit ihrer
15-jährigen Tochter gekommen weiß von
harten Auseinandersetzungen auch in den
Schulen gerade Jugendliche sagen uns das
dass die hier tatsächlich auch unter
Beschuss stehen auch in Schulen und so
das wissen wir ja also es ist sehr
geteilte Meinung in meinem Freundeskreis
also sehr viele Leute sind anderer
Meinung als ich und dann kommt es immer
mal zu Meinungsverschiedenheiten und
auch ein bisschen
zu Auseinandersetzungen und das ist
nicht ganz so cool auch im thüringischen
Sonneberg ist es nicht so einfach die
Massen auf die Straße zu holen es ist
hier die erste Demo gegen
Rechtsextremismus in diesem Jahr denn
seitdem in dieser Kleinstadt im letzten
Jahr 52% für einen AFD Kandidaten als
Landrat gestimmt haben hat sich die
Stimmung stark verändert also dieses
gegeneinander hat ja extrem zugenommen
und das wollen wir ja aber nicht wir
wollen ja miteinander ja es gibt Freunde
mit denen kann man da drüber reden aber
es gibt auch bewusst Freunde bei dem
muss man leider solche Themen ignorieren
mein Sohn ist ein tranzmann und der hat
in der Tat Angst hierher zugehen der
geht nur noch nach kubok zum Einkaufen
etwa 300 Leute waren es immerhin die
sich in Sonneberg getraut haben und auch
wie im sächsischen Freiberg darauf
hoffen dass die Demos in den kleinen
Städten noch größer werden und nur damit
das klar ist diese Demonstrationen jetzt
schon seit Wochen und bundesweit sind
auch insofern ein interessantes
gesellschaftliches Phänomen weil hier
plötzlich die analoge Welt Gesicht zeigt
und damit auch reale
Mehrheitsverhältnisse sichtbar macht
Politbarometer etwa sagen
79% dass sie die Demos gegen
Rechtsextremismus gut finden ist man
hingegen in der digitalen Welt auf
Social Media unterwegs kann man ja
oftmals den Eindruck gewinnen dass eine
Mehrheit radikal und aggressiv sei und
wahlweise den Staat ablehnt oder den
Angriffskrieg der Russen relativiert und
so weiter die Frage ist nur wie diese
Verzerrungen auf die Gesellschaft
zurückwirken wie sie das erstärken
radikaler Kräfte
befördern dabei fing das vor genau 20
Jahren so hübsch an als Facebook
gegründet wurde dazu gleich noch ein
Gespräch zuvor berichtet s
ren Volksdorf ist ein beschaulicher
Stadtteil im g Norden und ein gut
vernetzter seit mehr als 8 Jahren
tauschen sich inzwischen fast 5000
Facebooknutzer aus dem Stadtteil in
einer privaten Gruppe des sozialen
Netzwerkes aus Karina schillak ist eine
von drei AdministratorInnen sprich sie
passt auf den guten Ton auf der ist auch
in der nachbarschaftsgruppe in den
vergangenen drei Jahren rauer geworden
es darf gerne auch mal hitziger werden
die Gruppe heißt ja auch Volksdorf
Austausch so sollen sich austauschen wir
wollen auch gar keine Meinung im Keim
steticken das ist auch nicht förderlich
aber wenn es dann zu persönnlich wird
oder auch zu politisch dann schreiten
wir schon ein und dann also erstmal
verwaren wir eigentlich und bitten DAAD
drum sich zu mäßigen und wenn es gar
nicht geht dann nehmen wir halt auch
Kommentare raus vor 20 Jahren hatte
Harvard Student Mark Zuckerberg das Buch
der Gesichter gegründet um hauptsächlich
mit kommolitoninen in Kontakt zu kommen
aus der kleinen Kontaktbörse ist ein
Unternehmen mit riesigem Einfluss
geworden mit riesigem datensammelhunger
und mit unter sehr gefährlichen Inh
die nutzte etwa die britische Firma
Cambridge analytica zur
Wahlbeeinflussung dazu kommen jeden Tag
persönliche Angriffe verschwörungsmüten
oder hasskommentare facebook hat mit zu
einem System beigetragen das ist der
Eindruck zumindest bei dem
emotionalisierende oft wütend maende
Inhalte besonders viel Reichweite
erziähen und dafür ist Facebook schon
selbstverantwortlich mittlerweile gibt's
ein ganzes potpie von Seiten die
teilweise noch ter vielleicht auch noch
schriller sind aber der große Riese am
Markt ist immer noch Facebook und hat
diese Verantwortung auch selbst zu
tragen 2,1 Milliarden Menschen sind
weltweit täglich auf Facebook aktiv das
ist fast die Hälfte aller Social Media
Nutzer die lauten und verstörenden Töne
kommen derzeit eher vom Netzwerk Ex dem
ehemaligen Twitter bei dem Besitzer Eon
Musk fast alle prüfschranken abgebaut
hat auch telegram und tiktok
polarisieren die ikation im öffentlichen
Raum sich brutal verändert hat in den
letzten 10 bis 20 Jahren daran kann
glaube ich kein Zweifel sein wir
diskutieren direkt D miteinander wir
diskutieren vielleicht auch polarisieren
D miteinander also die gesamte
Öffentlichkeit hat sich stark verändert
die Bedeutung von Medien hat sich stark
verändert insofern haben soziale
Netzwerke auf unsere Debattenkultur auf
unsere politische Kultur sehr starke
Auswirkung Mark Zuckerberg möchte mit
seinem in Meta umbenannten Konzern neue
Welten erschaffen eine Flucht vom Text
Schmuddel Image in einen virtuellen
online trereffpunkt die Hoffnung wer
sich selbst wenn auch nur digital in die
Augen schaut pöbelt weniger der
bildgenerator von chatgpt traut dieser
Zukunft aber noch nicht so ganz und
zeichnet nach der Sprachkultur bei
Facebook gefragt ein eher trauriges
Bild und darüber wollen wir mit einem
Fachmann sprechen mit Markus Beckedahl
Gründer der Plattform netzpolitik.org
und der digitalkonferenz republicaa und
er war außerdem in einer enet des
Bundestags über Internet und digitale
Gesellschaft guten Abend Herr
beckedal guten Abend wenn man sich die
Probleme anguckt über die jetzt so
geklagt wird Hetze Hass Fakes kann es
sein dass die eigentlich gar nicht
lösbar sind weil s es da um das Kern des
Ganzen Geschäftsmodells
geht ja das ist leider Teil des Problems
wenn man konsequent gegen Hass und Hetze
vorgehen wollen würde und all die
negativen Nebenwirkungen die uns bei
allen positiven Beispielen diese
Plattform bringen dann müsste man ans
Geschäftsmodell ran dann müsste man ganz
klar das Geschäftsmodell der
personalisierten Werbung verbieten weil
das befördert all diese Mechanismen die
wiederum Populismus Hass und Hetze
befördern und das ist das Problem das
möchte nämlich keiner bzw starke Lobbys
der Unternehmen der Verleger wehren sich
dagegen ja dieses Geschäftsmodell zu
verbieten vielleicht könnten sie noch
mal erklären wie dieser Algorithmus
eigentlich funktioniert warum dieses
Geschäftsmodell auch eben mit und
Empörung und Erregung zu tun
hat ja das Geschäftsmodell basiert
darauf dass wir so möglichst viel
Aufmerksamkeit auf diesen Plattformen
binden dass wir möglichst viele
Datenpunkte hinterlassen dass wir zu
möglichst vielen Interaktionen angereizt
werden damit ja diese Unternehmen
möglichst gute Profile über uns unsere
Vorlieben sammeln können um Werbung
auszustrahlen also mit anderen Worten
diese Unternehmen wie Facebook verkaufen
Werbeplätze und dafür sollen wir
angeregt werden möglichst viel mit
anderen zu interagieren und dadurch
werden vor alleningen polarisierende
Inhalte befördert auf die Überholspuren
gebracht und Menschen die skrupellos
sind bespielen dann diese Mechanismen
und deswegen haben wir so viel hassätze
Desinformation und Halbwahrheiten auf
diesen Plattform die ja auch zum Teil
werden und auch staatlicherseits
organisiert werden also wenn man an die
Russen Trolle sieht die inzwischen jetzt
weniger Trolle sondern mehr Bots
geworden sind man weiß das jetzt
eigentlich seit mindestens 10 Jahren
aber es ist irgendwie kein Kraut dagegen
gewachsen scheint
es ja wir haben es leider mit vielen
Menschen zu tun die sehr viel Geld haben
die skrupellos sind und diese
Mechanismen einfach skrupellos bespielen
früher brauchte man dafür noch viele
Menschen die dann quasi als Troll
Armee online Stimmung gemacht haben
heutzutage kann man davon sehr viel
automatisieren und das Ziel ist immer na
ja Halbwahrheiten
Stimmungen ja Meinungen zu simulieren um
ja auch Gesellschaften zu
destabilisieren oder bestimmte Meinungen
und Positionen
bevorzugt durch die Mechanismen sichtbar
zu zu machen und das ist ein Problem
dass das relativ intransparent abläuft
und eigentlich dann auch nur eine Frage
von Geld und Ressourcen ist n wird ja
auch viel darüber diskutiert was Elon
Musk aus aus Twitter gemacht hat also
nun mehr Ex und manche Institutionen
überlegen auch oder einzelne Personen
Parteien und so weiter überlegen auch ob
man nicht da von diesen Plattformen die
sich nicht vielleicht einfach ganz
verabschieden sollte kann das eine
Lösung sein quasi Abstimmung mit den
Füßen ja das kann eine Lösung sein vor
allen Dingen beim Beispiel Twitter Ex
sozusagen was von einem offen
antisemitisch agierenden Multimilliardär
geführt wird der einseitig ja über Nacht
Regeln ändert allerdings sollte man sich
fragen wo man hingehen möchte ich würde
dafür pläeren dass wir dezentrale offene
Plattformen bevorzugen das könnte auch
eine Aufgabe des öffentlichrechtlichen
Rundfunks sein in der Zukunft hier
stärker aktiv zu werden sowohl in Sachen
contentmeration als auch eigene Inhalte
dort
auszuspielen damit wir Plattformen
beleben
die nicht in der Hand von einzelnen
multimilliardären sind aber das sind
diese Milliardäre die eben die großen
Firmen haben die dann auch weltweit
agieren also die wenigsten Leute wollen
wahrscheinlich bei einem nur deutschen
werer nur deutschen Plattform oder mit
sozialen Netzwerk unterwegs
sein ich kann mir vorstellen dass
dezentrale datenschutzfreundliche
Netzwerke die Zukunft darstellen die
international Funk funktionieren die
lokal betrieben werden das funktioniert
nach ähnlichen Prinzipien wie E-Mail sie
können bei einem deutschen Anbieter eine
E-Mailadresse haben oder zu einem großen
Konzern gehen oder sich auch einen
eigenen Mailserver betreiben das kann
die Zukunft sein ich habe die Hoffnung
dass wir eine lebenswertere digitale
Zukunft vorfinden werden wir müssen
daran bauen und ja alle gemeinsam dafür
kämpfen beckedall danke Ihnen für das
Gespräch danke Ihnen
das Interview haben wir vor einer Stunde
geführt und jetzt geht's erstmal mit den
Nachrichten weiter US-Präsident Joe
Biden hat die erste offizielle Vorwahl
der Demokraten im Bundesstaat South
Carolina klar gewonnen beiden kommt nach
Auszählung fast aller Stimmen auf rund
96% bei einer allerdings eher geringen
Wahlbeteiligung die Abstimmung gilt als
wichtiger Stimmungstest für den
demokratischen Amtsinhaber der bei der
Präsidentenwahl im November für eine
zweite Amtszeit antreten
will die USA haben erneut aus der Luft
Stellungen der huthi im Yemen
angegriffen gemeinsam mit den
Streitkräften Großbritanniens und mit
der Unterstützung weiterer Länder
attackierten sie 36 Ziele an 13 Orten im
Jemen die mit dem Iran Verbündeten huthi
die immer wieder internationale
Handelsschiffe im Roten Meer beschießen
kündigten Vergeltung
an in Paris können die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger über höhere par Gebühren für
Geländewagen entscheiden die
Stadtverwaltung will die Preise für SUV
im Zentrum verdreifachen von aktuell 6 €
auf 18 € pro Stunde die höheren Gebühren
treffen nur Besucher Anwohner wären von
der Erhöhung ausgenommen das Ergebnis
der Befragung wird noch heute Abend
erwartet lange wurde gebaut seit heute
Nachmittag ist ein Teilstück der neuen
Leverkusener A1 Rheinbrücke für den
Verkehr freigegeben worden 2017 war mit
dem Bau der neuen Brücke begonnen worden
die aus zwei nebeneinander stehenden
Teilen zusammengesetzt werden soll das
erste ist jetzt fertig neben der alten
Brücke die nun abgerissen wird damit
dann an der Stelle die zweite teilbrücke
entsteht im Juni ist ja Europawahl eine
Wahl die eigentlich nur in
Mitgliedsländern der Europäischen Union
stattfindet die nur diese Länder etwas
angeht und in der nur Parteien dieser
Mitgliedsländer antreten das ist
eigentlich logisch und
selbstverständlich doch nun hat sich in
einigen EU-Ländern auch in Deutschland
eine neue Vereinigung namens dava
gegründet die bei der europaahl antreten
will und die als Ableger der Partei des
türkischen Präsidenten Erdogan gilt
Susanna Santina
berichtet der türkische Autokrat Erdogan
schafft es immer wieder hier zuande die
Massen zu begeistern wie nach der
Präsidentenwahl im letzten Jahr kommt
nun mit dava der nächste Schritt um sich
weiter politischen Einfluss in
Deutschland und Europa zu sichern auf
Platz 1 der Liste für die Europawahl
steht fati Singal bis vor kurzem
Führungsmitglied der UID eine
Lobbyorganisation von Erdogans Partei
AKP mit Erdogan habe da war aber nichts
zu tun und all diejenigen die das
behaupten die müssen das erstmal
beweisen wir möchten über Probleme mit
von Menschen sprechen mit türkischer
Zuwanderungsgeschichte mit muslimischen
background was für Probleme sie
innerhalb der deutschen Gesellschaft
haben wir möchten uns über latenten
Rassismus unterhalten der gründungs
versteht fati Singal hat als UID
Funktionär jahrelang die
Wahlberechtigten für den türkischen
Präsidenten
mobilisiert wer wird der nächste
Präsident der
Türkei auch die anderen dava
Spitzenkandidaten haben klare
Verbindungen nach Ankara mustafa
joldasch war Funktionär der Organisation
milig görrisch die vom Verfassungsschutz
als islamistisch eingestuft wird und Ali
isanli Funktionär bei ditip dem
türkischmuslimischen Dachverband der der
Religionsbehörde di Janet in Ankara
untersteht und die Präsident
Erdogan da war sie eine Gefahr für das
Zusammenleben in Deutschland sagt Erin
gyin man versucht jetzt auch über die
politische Ebene Einfluss zu nehmen und
vor allem halt auch die türkische
Diaspora für die AKP Agenda nutzbar zu
machen auf der politischen Bühne das
muss man ernst nehmen da will sich an
alle Muslime richten die sich von der
deutschen Politik nicht berücksichtigt
fühlten das größte Wählerpotenzial sieht
sie bei den türkeistämmigen etwa 2,8
Millionen leben in Deutschland davon
haben rund 1,5 Millionen die deutsche
Staatsangehörigkeit durch die
Neuregelung beim Doppelpass könnten mehr
als eine Million potenzielle Wähler dazu
kommen sicherlich werden nicht alle
türkeistemmigen dava wählen der csuchef
sieht sich dennoch bestätigt wir
brauchen keine Beeinflussung von
außerhalb und deswegen soll die Ampel
auch noch mal über
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht nachdenken ob
diese schnelle Einbürgerung nicht noch
ein zusätzlicher Schub sein könnte
gerade für die Pläne von Erdogan wir
lehnen es jedenfalls ab kein Problem hat
Markus Söder dagegen mit dem
türkischmuslimischen Dachverband geht
regelmäßig zum Fastenbrechen zu diep
mein Appell an die CDU CSU ist statt
sich im Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht
abzuarbeiten guck mal mit wem ihr euch
trefft und nicht da so reden in der
deutschen Öffentlichkeit und den
türkischen Verein dann kuscheln das
machen fast alle deutschen Parteien auch
das muss man ein Ende haben Ziel sei
jetzt sagt uns fati Singal aus dava so
schnell wie möglich eine Partei zu
machen und dann bei Kommunalwahlen und
der Bundestagswahl anzutreten als
Werbegesicht wünsche er sich
mesutösi der Staatschef von Chile sagt
dass sein Land gerade die schlimmste
Tragödie seit 14 Jahren erlebt damals
hat ein schweres Erdbeben das
südamerikanische Land erschüttert jetzt
sind es zahlreiche Waldbrände die seit
Tagen wüten vor allem in
dichtbesiedelten Gebieten westlich der
Hauptstadt Santiago mutmaßlich spielt
dabei auch Brandstiftung eine Rolle die
Behörden melden aktuell 99 tote hunderte
werden aber noch vermisst die Brände
unter Kontrolle zu bekommen ist schwer
die aktuelle Hitzewelle Trockenheit und
starke Winde bereiten den
Feuerwehrleuten massive Probleme was
frerat
berichtet das Feuer kommt viel zu
schnell von mehreren Seiten
unberechenbar und gnadenlos auf geht's
Weg hier
kommt immer wieder muss die chilenische
Feuerwehr das Feld räumen der in Region
walparaiso westlich der Hauptstadt
Santiago kämpfen sie gegen eine
Naturgewalt deren Kräfte noch lange
nicht am Ende zu sein scheinen die Zahl
der Toten und Vermissten steigt noch
immer
an es war schrecklich ich habe noch nie
in meinem Leben eine solche Angst gehabt
solche eine
Situation meine Stadt
brennt und ich bin immer noch so
erschüttertil mein so sehr gefürchtet
hat es war also zu sagen es war wie die
Hölle wäre noch
untertrieben in Wien delm neben
walparaiso hat das Feuer ein Gaslager
erreicht der Feuerwehr bleibt nur der
Rückzug tausende Anwohner sind auf der
Flucht Menschen die weiter von den
Brandherden entfernt leben wurden
dagegen aufgefordert in ihren Häusern zu
bleiben damit die Rettungsdienste
durchkommen die Feuerwehr hat bislang
keine die bränd unter Kontrolle zu
bringen wir haben hier Winde von 40 bis
50 Stunden Kilom das ist ein Problem
weil der Wind kleine Zweige und Blätter
mit sich trägt die weitere Feuer
anfachen Chiles Präsident Gabriel borit
hat den Ausnahmezustand verhängt und das
Militär zur Hilfe entsandt aufgrund der
Vielzahl der gleichzeitig ausgebrochenen
Brandherde gibt es den Verdacht dass
einige Feuer absichtlich gelegt worden
sein
könnten wenn es diese Leute gibt werden
wir sie jagen und sie werden nicht nur
mit der Ablehnung der Gesellschaft
insgesamt sondern auch mit der ganzen
Härte des Gesetzes konfrontiert werden
das Ausmaß der Katastrophe ist noch
nicht abzusehen der Präsident hat zwei
Tage Staatstrauer
angeordnet und jetzt noch mal Heinz mit
dem Blick auf den Sport an diesem
Wochenende zerst zur Fußball Bundesliga
mit zwei Spielen heute Wolfsburg und
Hoffenheim trennten sich Unentschieden
2:2 und Leipzig hat 2:0 gegen Union
Berlin
gewonnen die Deutschen hockeymänner sind
Hallen Europameister im Hockey bei der
EM in Belgien gewann das Team das
Endspiel gegen Polen mit
5:2 auch ohne einige für Olympia
geschonte Leistungsträger dominiert die
deutsche Mannschaft das Finale es dauert
bis ins zweite Viertel eher eine
Strafecke die Führung bringt Kapitän
döch mit einem scharfen Ball in den
Winkel kurz vor der Pause bringt Masur
das Team erneut in Führung 2:1 nach 20
Minuten in der zweiten Hälfte ist das
deutsche Team immer überlegener Pass in
die Tiefe auf markur sein zweiter
Treffer unter dem polnischen Schlussmann
hindurch zum 5 Z2 stand vollendet dann
mertkens Deutschland ist Europameister
im Hallenhockey zum 17 Mal
bereits Andreas Wellinger hat das
Weltcup Schispringen im heimischen
Willingen gewonnen bei schwierigen
Wettkampfbedingungen landete er mit 149
m auf Platz 1 vor dem Japaner Kobayashi
und dem Schweizer
Deschwanden und auch bei den Bob
Wettbewerben lief es aus deutscher Sicht
erfolgreich Juniorenweltmeister Adam
Amur hat sich mit seinem Bruder isam als
Anschieber den em titlm zweier Bob
geholt Silber ging an den Schweizer
Michael Vogt Titelverteidiger Johannes
Lochner musste sich nach einem Fehler
mit Rang 3
begnügen und bei den Frauen ging em Gold
im Zweierbob an Laura Nolte und ihre
Anschieberin Silber gewann Teamkollegin
Kim kaliki vor der Schweizerin Melanie
Hasler das Schöne an der Ernennung der
europäischen Kulturhauptstädte ist ja
das häufig Orte ausgewählt werden die
keine klassischen Touristenziele sind
von denen in anderen Teilen Europas
viele vielleicht sogar noch nie gehört
haben und nun aber viele Berichte zu
sehen bekommen z.B aus
Budde die norwegische Stadt liegt ganz
hoch im Norden sogar noch nördlich des
Polarkreises und ist Hauptstadt der
Provinz Nordland sie sieht auf Bildern
vielleicht etwas verträumt aus gilt aber
schon länger als arktischer
kulturhotspot an diesem Wochenende wurde
das Jahr als Kulturhauptstadt feierlich
eröffnet und die eher raue Wetterlage
die gehört einfach dazu Eindrücke aus
Bud von class
Thomson ein Ponton im Hafenbecken vom
Sturm und toost und nur mit kleinen
bödchen zu erreichen man muss schon
unerschrocken und der Natur nah sein um
ein Jahr als europäische
Kulturhauptstadt so einzuluten so sind
wir zeigen die Menschen hier am
Polarkreis gemeinsam Spaß haben
rausgehen die Natur
genießen so wie Anne Margareta die Sami
Frau hat sich ein paar ihrer Liebsten
Rentiere vom Land nach bdö geholt in
eine Art Mini samiwelt mit einer Kote
dem klassischen samizelt und viel
Gemütlichkeit trotz des naskalten
Wetters hier am Rande des
poleeres europäische Kulturhauptstadt
das bedeutet für sie vor allem eines mit
der Welt ins Gespräch zu
kommen es ist toll unsere ursprüngliche
Lebensweise zeigen zu können so kann uns
jeder kennenlernen und das macht es
wiederum für unsere künftigen
Generationen leichter die Kultur
lebendig zu halten erstmals präsentiert
sich eine Stadt nördlich des
Polarkreises als europäische
Kulturhauptstadt dort wo es kalt und
einsam ist könnte man meinen für die
Crew des Berliner Künstlerkollektivs
Phase 7 die das Event mit den Norwegern
auf die Beine stellen eine anrührende
Erfahrung dass es hier keineswegs
trostlos ist oh so toll sie sehen so
toll aus die Fische schau doch mal
da inmitten der fischtrohle am Hafen
wird einer hiesigen Ikone gehuldigt dem
Kabeljau von ihm lebt die Region seit
Jahrhunderten das Programm der
Kulturhauptstadt will nah an den
Menschen sein und die Boder
zusammenbringen vielleicht ist Kultur
hier noch wichtiger als in den größeren
Städten im Süden Norwegens es gibt
Zeiten in denen es dunkel und kalt ist
und dann sagen wir hier das ist noch
wichtiger ist dass das Herz warm ist
wenn man also Kultur in dem Sinne
begreift dass es um menschliche
Begegnung geht dann halte ich sie
Fürtig zur Natur im Zelt gucken eine
eisige Modenschau in der Fußgängerzone
auf die Beine stellen oder ein Konzert
nach dem Einkauf in einem Laden
improvisieren statt einsam am Computer
zu shoppen den Feiernden im Norden geht
es um Gemeinschaft man hat einfach mehr
Möglichkeiten mehr Plätze an die man
gehen kann mehr Menschen die man treffen
kann der beste Ort für Sami Frau Anne
Margareta für Gemeinsamkeit ist das
Feuer im Zelt mit ihrer Schwester ein
Tee trinken miteinander sprechen das
schafft Wärme und Verbundenheit etwas
woran BDE als Kulturmetropole erinnern
möchte gleich folgt dann auch noch unser
Wetter aber vorher noch wie immer
sonntags der Ausblick auf die neue Woche
von Erik
[Musik]
illenseeher ein Etappenziel muss her für
die CO2 Einsparung der EU bis 2040 die
Kommission will am Dienstag dem
Parlament Szenarien vorstellen erwartet
wird eine Vorgabe von mindestens 90%
weniger CO2 gegenüber dem Jahr 1990 und
die Feststellung wir müssen uns alle
mehr anstrengen er hat was im Gepäck
wenn Kanzler Scholz am Donnerstag in die
USA reist die EU hat gerade Milliarden
Militärhilfen für die Ukraine
freigegeben Präsident bidens Hilfspaket
steckt seit Monaten fest im Kongress
Kanzler Scholz will helfen und auch mit
abgeordnet sprechen tschüss Hase und
hallo Drache China und andere asiatische
Länder läuten am Samstag ein neues Jahr
ein einmal mehr machen sich aber
Millionen Menschen auf den Weg zu ihren
Familien in diesem Jahr gibt es in China
kaum noch coronauauflagen es könnte eine
rekordreisewelle werden runde 2 der
Bundestagswahl
2021 in Berlin am kommenden Sonntag
wegen zahlreicher Pannen damals
entschied das Bundesverfassungsgericht
in einem Teil der Wahl Bezirke muss noch
einmal gewählt werden betrifft etwa
550.000 Wahlberechtigte egal wie es
ausgeht die Machtverhältnisse im
Bundestag bleiben
gleich und jetzt die Wetteraussichten
zum Start in die neue Woche Morgen zieht
sich der Regen im Norden Richtung Ostsee
zurück von Süden her zeigt sich bis zur
Mitte die Sonne bei im Norden starkem
Wind werden 6 bis 12 im Süden bis zu 16°
erreicht auch die nächsten Tage werden
sehr windig im Süden mit Sonne sonst
regnet es zum Teil ergiebig am
Donnerstag im Nordosten mit Schnee dort
wird es kälter im Süden bleibt es sehr
mild das war's von uns an diesem
Sonntagabend und um 0:30 Uhr gibt es
dann die nächste heute Express und hier
erwarten Sie morgen abend Donia Hayali
und Hanna Zimmermann
[Musik]
wiedersehen